for the rugby faithful in Europe
occasions don't come much bigger than
the six nations with its traditions of
unity and friendship even among Rivals
it attracts hundreds of thousands of
fans each year it is the best tournament
in the world best tournament in the
world most fans can't get to the World
Cup so it's probably the biggest a good
party with friends it's really uh
another rugby tradition is a pioneering
approach to technology and the sport is
leading the way again at the Six Nations
kicking off another tech Revolution on
the pitch
this is a smart ball it contains a micro
chip that tracks its movement its speed
even how much it's spinning and like
Rugby's previous Innovations it could
eventually change how other sports are
played officiated and watched sensors
around the field receive signals from
the microchip and send them to
technicians from the Bulls designers
sportable so we have uh Jordan and
Connell out here on the pitch passing
back and forth and instantly I can see
the data coming through on our system
Jordan's going to do a pass there
mimicking a scrum half so we can see
there his pass was 0.3 seconds ground
reload which is pretty quick the data is
handled by analytics company Sage which
also works in qriket and Major League
Baseball giving teams instant insights
into the effectiveness of their tactics
and their players during the match the
idea came from former NASA scientist
Peter husamaya while he was watching a
game of ice hockey the problems faced in
rugby are similar problems faced by a
lot of Ball Sports it's being able to
track the ball to know what the ball's
doing and how the players are
manipulating it in real time we're
trying to give teams the tools they need
to monitor player performance with
respect to kicking and passing for fans
being able to know instantly the
territory gain the distance and then the
last part was we're trying to give
referees another set of eyes there are
many problems that the smart ball can
solve out the box that a human just
can't the balls have USB inputs and can
currently be seen charging on the
sidelines of the Six Nations early
attack introduced by rugby such as video
referees took almost 20 years to be
adopted by football the designers hope
other sports will be plugging and
playing with a smart ball a lot sooner
than that Polaris Al Jazeera London